sneakerheads this one is for you there's
a local convention this weekend that
wants to help you stay fleet flea kick
sneaker convention owner shamar wall and
siobhan wilson are here to officially
give us the dope invite and i had to
wear my sneakers for y'all so excited
for this now first before we get to the
the nitty gritty here
flee
yes now we've heard state fly but what
is state fleet stay free just like a
term you know like as a flea they always
stay on you
just determine the swag just flee like
the swag just stay on you know three
kicks you always got the kicks on safely
i like that stay free okay now tell us
about introduce us to flea kicks and
just the company and what you guys are
doing so flea kick started off as a
resale company what we did was we bought
sneakers and then we sold them to
anybody with an upsell price okay so
like anything that was sold out you
would come to us and you will buy them
now we do sneaker conventions so what we
do now is we help other resellers so any
resellers that want to get their name
out and want to sell shoes that they
have been holding on we throw
conventions for them dope okay so on
sunday on the 18th you guys are having
your convention
this year
what can people expect we're seeing
video of it right now yeah so it's gonna
be amazing it's to be dope we also do a
3v3 competition as well so that's why
you got the ball
so we trying to bring the whole culture
together you know basketball snickers
just just go hand in hand so for sure
what to expect you have a lot of things
like sneakers you have clothing anybody
that has local clothing brands come out
you have people that do rugs you got
people that sell key chains you have
people that do paintings so it's not
just sneakers it's just people all
around us involved in that community
like when they come like street fashion
streetwear that's what you expect at the
show it's the whole vibe okay so let's
break it down we got a little sample
this is just a small table versus how
many shoes will you guys have it's 80
vendors
so you're thinking you could put like 30
sneakers on the table 80 times 30. you
can do the math exactly i'm a journalist
i don't do math all right let's let's
talk about these things what do we have
um so right here what we brought out is
we're doing a raffle as well three
rifles so the threes we have a raffle
one dollar raffle you can buy as many
rifles as you want and you can wear
these sneakers wow
and then we have the dunks you know
everybody loves it everybody loves it
everybody does the ducks these are the
colors yeah yeah super dope and what we
try to do is this is men's size and we
got a women's size as well so we try to
show love to both
i want to know about these right here
yes what size are these yeah we're super
excited to and now it's our sponsor uh
major waves oh i love major girls
yeah so they are coming out to be a big
sponsor they have a big 20 by 10 space
and what they're gonna do is free
sneaker giveaway and they're also gonna
do a couple lessons so we bought our
prayers they customized sneakers and you
can bring your sneakers in so we bought
them just to show you what all you can
do this is regular air forces it was
black now you can see we transformed
into something crazy so we kind of went
for like the off-white look that's so
cool yeah i'm so happy for you guys we
have to wrap up but tell everybody how
they can get tickets and come join you
tickets you can go to
fleakixonly.com you can also go to our
instagram my underscore free kicks only
facebook at flea kicks only as well you
can email us fleek it's only gmail.com
but the quickest way just go to the
website click the link you can grab your
ticket and the first 50 is free also oh
hello yeah first birthday through the
doors
perfect okay well have fun this weekend
thank you guys thank you so much